soba noodle is our tradition to eat
during new year's eve
toshikoshi soba means ear crossing
noodles
some people say one of the reason is
this buddhist temples
used to give sober to poor people on new
year's
and it's become a tradition to eat on
new year's eve
so what i know about this tradition i
saw soba noodle is very easy to prepare
and end of the year it's very busy
so they want to make a meal something
very quickly and easy
i'm not hundred percent sure what is the
origin story
if somebody knows please let me know so
one of our superstitions
is so far it's long so it's like
longevity of life
to eat soba noodle it's kind of good
luck thing
if you eat long soba noodles you will
have a longer life there's a bunch of
different superstitions about it too
sugar noodles are made with buckwheat so
it's gluten free
it has no gluten in it so it's very
difficult to make a home you need a
skill to make soba
if you want to know more about making
soba noodles
watch alvin's video the art of making
soba noodles
it's very beautiful video you can also
purchase the dried soba noodle
in the asian market or some grocery
stores
so one of the topping in the video is
called kaki again
it's type of tempura it's like veggie
medley bunch of different vegetables
coated with tempura butter and fried
usually you also include onion and
carrots
soda is usually either soft hot or cold
depending on the weather or your mood
cold soba come with dipping sauce
sort of like tsukemen noodle and warm
soba
come submerged in soup more like a ramen
or udon
yaksoda also has soda in their name
but it's completely different
ingredients
so yaki means punk fried for yakisoba
soba
is baku noodle last time i had a soba
noodle
i went with water team in tokyo someone
requested
soba and it turns out they're a famous
sofa shop nearby
and we went but we waited for 30 minutes
but it was really good
totally worth it i also ate soba noodles
when we shop in new york
i like eating soba noodles in the summer
time usually cold
because it's refreshing and light for
the winter time i like
warm soba noodles i usually will eat
soba noodles for new year's eve
it's a great way of connecting my
culture and my tradition
in my current life in l.a
[Music]
you